Yeah, I'm just going to say it. Okay. According to Steven's logic,
Dan is a PDF because the people who tend to most be PDFs, according
to Steven, are the people who call other people PDFs incessantly.
Dan calls other people PDFs incessantly. In addition to using
it both as a joke and as an insult and as an actual allegation,
spiteful kind of thing. If that is the case, according to Stephen
and just keeping and just trying to be consistent here, okay,
this is just me trying to use Steven's consistency. All right,
Dan has a higher likelihood of being a PDF than I am.
Maybe maybe just for fun. Just like I've heard it described to
me now. Maybe just for a little bit of fun. We check this out.
Okay. So, what's the haps here? This is a continuation of the
Dan versus Food Shops thing. Okay. Apparently, Food Shops goes
and reacts to Dan's VOD.
>> Yeah, I'm China. Okay.
Why? Why did that come through? Why is that the only
supposedly there's some big truth I was begging? [__]
My mic is quiet. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here. Here
it is. Here it is. Here it is. >> All right. Let's go.
Let's go. >> Never said anything about this person. Oh,
[__] By the way, food shops, okay? And by the way,
[__] anyone who's off the drawing uh art that makes
them think it's a kid. Okay, I don't give a [__]
All right, supposedly there's some big truce I was begging from.
That did not happen. Okay, I'm going to tell you right now, don't
give a creepy ass mother. Stay the [__] away from
me. Don't come near me. Like the whole thing about not talking
about them. Yeah, cuz I don't >> Hold on. Hold on. That's
not That'sed up, Dan. This is like your best friend. This is
yours in Destiny's best friend. She's done so much work for you
guys. Come on, Dan. Just play Arc Raiders with her again. I'm
sure nobody will notice. Come on. Come on. >> Talk about
someone that's like literally off thinking that there's a kid
on the
>> Oh my lord.
I didn't even do anything.
Just so you guys know, I didn't even Oh, dude. Why?
just Yeah, I I guess I I told you guys I told you guys he was
going to break the ceasefire first.
I I told you guys
>> to be fair. I also called that by virtue of the tattoo
on his back. Okay, THESE GUYS THESE GUYS KNEW A THING or two
about breaking ceasefires. All right, >> he was going to
break the ceasefire first. And look what happened. He breaks
the ceasefire first. Unironically,
I What? Dude, come on. What?
It's crazy how I could just predict that off of one tattoo. There's
like a There was just one tattoo. I just predicted that off of
one tattoo. Wait, is that tattoo real? I It was real. I do believe.
So, it was 100% real. I've seen video of it with of him with
it on his back. It is real.
But I do believe he actually started getting it removed because
of rising anti-semitism. Not joking. I have heard this. Dan has
a huge Star of David on his back. Pan has a huge Star of David
on his back. >> Well, this is like just about the worst
way that you can break a ceasefire, too. It's not even a justified
reason because you already know you already knew about all of
this. You already came to terms about the same exact thing. How
is it How is it possible?
How is it possible that um that you >> your your existence
is a threat to Dan's existence? Okay. By virtue of that, he can
never break a ceasefire under false pretenses or in an unjustified
way. Your existence is a threat to his existence. Okay? You must
be removed. This community was promised to Dan 3,000 years ago.
Okay? This community promised to Dan 3,000 years ago. You have
to get the [__] out. >> Break the ceasefire
over um
over something you already came to terms with before.
Like this isn't big dulging new information. Um
this isn't
particular. Oh, dude.
Dude, are you >> Dude, yeah, he Yeah, he just literally
got mad about something he already knew.
Wait, but he also said food shops lied and that there was no
truce. He said he said it was a lie and there was no truce. Come
on, man. Show us that there was a truce.
Why? Just by the way. Okay. Um,
my editor is currently editing the ceasefire video.
He's like midprogress
midprogress ceasefire video. >> Well, Dan said he didn't
agree to that ceasefire. Dan said that ceasefire didn't exist.
>> Yo, bro. Wow. Wow. He actually has no spying. He He
legitimately, unironically,
is like one of the most
like one of the worst people on the entire internet. No, this
person thinks Dan doesn't have a right to exist. Dan has a right
to exist.
>> And it's like, oo, it's a loophole. It's drawn. So,
I get to do it. I'm good. >> You know what, Radiant? It's
time to release the DMs. Both between you and me and you and
Dan. Okay. All right. >> Oh, leak those DMs.
Show me that Dan lied. Uhoh, dude.
Time to hit back. No, no, no. Sweatpants, we're being transparently
biased here. We're taking food shop's side because it's very
funny that Dan and Destiny basically play video games all the
time with an actual That's just very funny to us. Okay, so we're
just taking Food Chop's side here. Food Job's going to win this
one. >> Okay, might as well leak it all. All right, because
at this point at this >> I need to know what is actually
going on. Okay, I need to review and see what's actually going
on. All right, there has to be a mis No, this isn't a communication
error. Sorry. I don't think this is a communication error, to
be honest. I think I think this is Dan unironically being an
anti-fan of me or maybe even an anti-fan of Destiny at this point.
Like what the off forever
>> I'm I got to get the the right sound levels on this.
Okay, but I do want this cuz this this is like where my heart
is right now. Okay, we got some Eurob beat going on in the background.
Leak it. Let's go. Leak it. Leak it all. Leak it
man is JTO. You're JCO now. You're JTO. No, you're No, you you're
JTO.
You're you're a JTO man. You're a J. You're >> Is he?
>> To be in Dan's defense, kneeling to food shops was like
the biggest aura loss of all time. So, in his defense, like his
manhood was legitimately threatened by >> Guys, is just
a drink. A martini shaken, not stirred. >> What? contributing
to the war chest and recovery efforts for the victims of Dantober
7th. >> Dixie, thank you so much for the $5. You guys should
also donate. Okay, one more.
One more. Every every dollar donated is a dollar to Spite Dan
now. Okay.
>> Every dollar donated is is a dollar to Spite Dan. Holy.
What? This This is completely out of left field. Okay. Completely.
All right.
There is no 400 IQ move to reignite the drama. There is no 500
IQ plan nothing. Okay. I I'm just very confused. I don't I don't
chat said, "Does this mean Dan will go after Destiny O2? Does
it? I don't know. I've heard Dan I've heard Dan occupies space
in the Jtock Discord. It's kind of anti-fan behavior if you ask
me. >> I I don't get it. I don't understand.
Oh, hey Sharp. All it takes is infinite." Dude, really? It's
about his manhood. Magabus, the title of the video will be this.
Dan breaks ceasefire over manhood. O o o o o o o o o o o o o
over something over toxic masculinity over something. I don't
know like this is clearly >> what the >> absolutely
incredible stuff. We got some
just the best mind at work here, guys. Damn. Break ceasefire
over
>> Just a drink a martini shaken not stirred. more top-heavy
sword ladies.
>> I I hear you. I hear you, but the game has too many
um topheavy sword ladies. I know that that's your thing, but
it it it's getting too much at this point. Okay. Like, it's just
we we can't even have one petite character. Just not even
FOOD CHOPS, NO. FOOD CHOPS, WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE YOUR SIDE. FOOD
CHOPS, STOP. STOP. STOP. STOP. STOP. STOP. STOP. STOP. OH, what
the
what the Oh god. It's just
Sorry, I'm I'm going to pause right there for a moment. >> These
these women all look like adults. I can't have one child. I can't
have
>> Anyone, by the way, who's doing any emote that's not
anything but a He's right is someone to put on a list right now.
Actually do like slash tag. Uh, this person probably does it
themselves. That's what I'm going to tell you right now. Like,
uh, >> we had a deal.
We had a deal. >> And you're pretending it's a gighat move
to break a deal. That's just about the most like non-manly thing
ever,
isn't
>> Dude, dude, hold on. POV Yaser Aerafat in the 2000s.
>> We had a deal. And you're pretending it's a gigachad
move to break a deal. That's just about the most like non-manly
thing ever,
isn't it? Isn't a man's word supposed to be like the part that
is supposed to be respected and honored or something? How could
you be? >> By the way, by the way, I have no idea if Yaserat
actually held to his own word. I I get the feeling he didn't
get the feeling he's kind of a scumbag. >> Breaking the
thing over your manhood,
but like But you're doing like the least manliest thing.
Like not like to be frank, this is like very unmanly of you.
Okay. Like I I don't know what else to say. Hello. >> Who
do we got in here? Who do we got? Who's like a hi? Is that really
the criticism? Lying is unmanly. Lying is not manly.
Is that I is that really I'm very lost here. Does this I don't
I don't get I I literally It's like Yeah, you're disingenuous.
You're duplicitous. Is she worried that she can't call him a
liar without being accused of anti-semitism or like what's going
on? >> Being a little bit defender any defenders on a list.
Okay, that's all I'm gonna say right now. And your time is limited.
>> By the way, I I don't think this is joking. Okay, I
I don't know. I don't know who's doing the mod and Bailey of
like, oh, he's just joking. He's just joking. None of this comes
off as joking to me, okay? He's not he's not doing it. He's not
going like, okay, just kidding. Just kidding. Right? Like remember
when I was like kind of making fun of Dan still? I'm not I'm
not saying like I always say just kidding. Just kidding. Just
kidding. Right. Just FYI. He's doing this over his manhood being
bro. >> Okay. It is actually.
>> Limited. Can't believe you people can >> Wow.
Yeah. I vote every election
>> The you know the worst ones are the ones that are like
Destiny defended this thing. It's like okay is he actually doing
that? Is he off the drawings of >> Why is that the line
that you draw? If you defend it, if you defend it, you enable
people like that to exist in your community, right?
Wait, so Destiny is different from me because
Destiny defends it, but he doesn't consume it? Wait, what?
Uh, no. Dan just doesn't want to call him. Dan doesn't have a
principal problem with this.
If trust me
if Dan fel found out tomorrow that Ethan was a
literally zero things would change in his life. Okay, you're
a loser and a that's why you lost. Okay, it's not trust me it's
not that it's not the thing. That is not it. Okay, that's not
the problem. You're fundamentally misunderstanding the problem.
You being a you having all these statements online indicating
attraction to children is being used to kill you, but it is not
actually a principal position from Dan that he doesn't like.
He's just using it to kill you.
>> Unlucky you realize. Wait.
>> Uh just a drink. >> I'm so confused. >> Shaken,
not stirred. >> Be generous in support of the anti-dan
>> stumbling. Thank you so much for the $2.
Why is
By the way,
he was referring to this. By the way, I say that with like I'm
not I'm not like I can tell food shops that she'll never be able
to win in this case, right? She'll never be able to beat Dan.
Dan didn't like that food shops flex the truce. She spit in his
face possibly.
I'm just I can throw this out here. I can say this to everybody.
They can be well aware of it. It literally doesn't matter. It
doesn't matter. I saw he was trying to abuse the rule 15 in the
subreddit. Okay. >> I don't know.
Is this about take? >> Oh, just to be clear. Oh, she keeps
doing this one thing where Desi says he doesn't care about
uh I'm totally fine people saying they don't care about our problem
with food shops is not the not caring about thing. It's all of
the other stuff.
IT'S ALL THE other stuff. Okay. So, what am I looking for? Oh,
also people are misunderstanding. The ceasefire is not the messages
about like, "Hey, you stop talking about me and I'll stop talking
about you." That's not the ceasefire, right? That wasn't the
ceasefire. There's something else that was explicitly negotiated
at that food shops has hinted at. She will leak DMs with like
the Radiant guy. Radiant needs to leak his DMs with Dam. By the
way, she's saying Radiant needs to leak her DMs with Dan and
their their DMs. I don't know, guy or girl. And then she wants
to leak her DMs with Radiant as well to show that she got offered
a ceasefire.
Now, here's the thing.
Radiant, I don't know anything about this Radiant guy.
Trust me, he's not siding with you, okay? Food shops. He's not
going down with the ship. No honor amongst thieves. You're a
sinking ship. He is going to jump away from you and go and hang
out with Dan and Mutin. Okay, that's what's going to happen.
That's that's how this is going to go. It won't matter if you're
right. It literally won't matter that everybody's going to leave.
That's how this is going to work. And I tell you this and I I
take no pleasure in it. By the way, a little bit, but I don't
take a lot of pleasure in it, okay? It's just how is it's the
space you joined. It's like the space you signed up for. That's
how it is. >> I about to drop a hot take about thousand-y
old spirits. >> Checks. What?
>> Just where? That's the most immediate >> The most
200 video ever. Okay.
Pick pick
Dan Saltman bends the knee. the zscotic anti-semitic PDF.
Let's go. Dan lost like it actually does not require bad faith
or malice or anything to think that
which is where that's the need. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Hold on, hold on. I don't know why Queen's channel didn't
just Ah, there we go. Hold on. She just wanted to skip past whatever
does not require >> Wait. Why did she want to skip past
whatever Queen was going to say here? Queen was going to say
something and then she skipped past it. What was the opinion
that he was going to give here? >> It actually does not
require bad faith or malice or anything to think that food is
a at all.
>> Oh well, THAT'S WHY SHE SKIPPED. OH.
OH. OH.
Better skip past that. Better skip past that. Uhoh. >> Almost
230 people and please move cast a >> By the way, Quimman
is an anti-fan.
Did you
>> Are we gonna Are we gonna engage with anything? No.
Literally doesn't Did she even listen to enough of this video
to hear what she's going to say? >> Just like clicked on
it, hit play, didn't like the first thing, clicked it forward,
didn't like the second thing. Oh, Queenman is an anti- fan. Actually,
>> this is the most flattering picture of me they could
have ever gotten for a Quan video ever. Okay, what is this? Like
it it actually does not require bad faith or malice or anything
to think
>> which is where that's the most immediate >> Almost
230 people. Please move cast a >> By the way, Queenman
is an anti-fan.
Did you Did you break Did you break Did you break the truce over
an anti-fan video? Are you an anti-fan at this point? Are you
around with this boy? Is this is this Can we collect some money
and buy food shops? Like voice training?
Are you
What the [__] Like this doesn't sound feminine, bro.
It's like It's really rough. It's rough for all of our ears.
Just talking whatever registers comfortable is unbearable. Okay.
Did you break the truth over
an anti-fan video? Are you an anti-fan at this point? Are you
an anti-fan? Why is your background so dark?
What, bro?
By the way, this is selfarm, okay? If you're consuming content
that >> I've long suspected that Dan is an anti-an Dan.
Dan the anti-fan man. Dan the anti-Dani
>> Anti-salt man. Okay. I've long suspected he's an anti-fan.
Long suspected. Okay. I've I've suspected from the very beginning
that his propensity to dox people, his propensity to go after
anyone around Hassan, his propensity to defend Destiny at all
costs. I've long suspected these are the traits of a true anti-fan.
Okay.
Yes. This is a great argument. Food shops. Yes. Yep. Donating
tens of thousands of dollars to become friends with Destiny in
the first place. Definitely anti-fan behavior. Absolutely. Makes
you mad and angry. Um,
and you feel as though like you're out of control and and you
feel as though
you feel as though you come out feeling worse when you are watching
a video, but you can't stop watching it. That's self. >> Oh,
is this like a Slay the Spire
clone? Do they make this game without like without it being for
>> I just noticed this is going to be like a Slay the Spire
clone.
that's self arm. All right. >> That are supposed to be
kids. Or is he just like doing it from like cuz he's the one
who's doing this said like is morally legal type. Okay. Cuz I
know one person that's actually off to pictures of kids. Stay
the [__] away from me. I'm good with that [__]
>> I mean like what is >> I mean Destiny didn't retain
that stuff for nothing. You know at least two. Dan, come on man.
Come on man. Come on man. Come on. Come on. Be real Dan. >> How
Destiny say. Right.
And by the way, the reason why I bring this up is because at
some point defending it, dude, >> her two arguments are
here's Destiny defending it and also Dan likes Jtock. Dan is
basically Jtock. Dan Jtock Dan Jtock. Dan Jtock. Destiny said
it this. Destiny said this. Destiny said this. Antifan. Antifan.
Antifan. Antifan. Antifan. Anti. And consuming it has no difference.
Okay. Almost no difference. Almost no difference. Okay. In fact,
it might be worse if you like if you really want to measure it
as something inherently bad.
>> It might actually be worse to defend it without consuming
it. Destiny may be more of a than food shops purely on the fact
that he doesn't off drawn pictures of kids, but will defend people
who do. When you think about it, >> it's worse to defend
it and not consume it than it is to consume it and
not defend it, which is me. Right. I I don't
what does she think she's doing when she plays the Destiny clip?
She says she consumes it and doesn't defend it and then she says
I don't defend it, but she's playing a Destiny clip of Destiny
defending it. Do you Do you Wait, do what do you think you're
doing there when you play that clip? >> Defend it? Like
I I don't defend it on my free time, right? I
>> Dude, you a whole manifesto. I've got that manifesto.
We can >> only bring it up when other people bring it up.
I Otherwise I >> can somebody Does anybody have the screenshot
of her graph that she did? Right. Does anybody have the the like
graphic representation of why her PCD isn't actually shut the
up about it? Right. So I'm not spreading or normalizing it in
any way. Right. Nor am I encouraging anybody to do something.
Cut back to about 3 minutes ago where she was like, "Huh, I hate
how all these women have like fully developed chests. I just
wish there was one. I just wish there was one in this game."
If Steven is defending but not consuming it, that objectively
according to you, that should have a worse effect because you're
enabling
something like that to exist in your community.
People take you more seriously, especially Destiny, right? So
yeah, actually I think that I think that going after me is hypocritical.
Okay, going after me is hypocritical. There has to be something
better to do with your time. Okay, like you can't do this all
day, right? How do you even find 3 hours to watch a Queenman
video? I would assume that you would have some business to crash
or did Dan say that he watched a Queenman video? I just I actually
don't know. Did Dan say that he watched it? I I might have missed
it. Time stamp for her graph. Okay. Did I miss her?
>> Did I miss Dan saying it? Maybe I missed Dan saying
it. Oh, this would be the the graph. Yes, this is she doesn't
defend it, but also here's the graph of explaining how her OCD
goes into PCD goes into anxiety on the consume.
Is this
PDFs are here? I just want to remind everybody. Hi, I'm Connor
and I approve this message every time.
Every time. I should I should take it easy on Connor. He did
name me
He did name me amongst the Stormlords. I do have to give him
that. Okay. >> Or some or some company that you want to
sell off like the previous 10 companies that you have had. All
right. Which all ended in failure. All right. You might want
to redact.dev
your um your response and your breaking of truth. Okay. Ironically
enough. Also, don't you dare
don't you dare talk about
protecting kids and this moral frogging about kids when you yourself,
okay, is responsible for some weird yourself,
Oh no,
she gonna pull out the Diddy Dan memes. She's gonna pull OUT
THE DIDDY DAN MEMES. Uh oh.
Hey Dan, were there were there were there minors groomed on tiny
chat? Hey Dan, were there she's about to go into those. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
>> The stuff about your
tiny chat, right? Your little >> Oh god. Oh no. There's
no way. Tiny chat. Oh god. There's no way she knows about a wrong
vine boom. I want the deep boom. There's no way she knows about
Hawaii, right? She can't possibly. She says Hawaii. It's all
over for Dan. weird [__] yourself. Okay. The stuff
about your
tiny chat, right? Your little app where apparently it was being
used by actual PDFs, not people like me who just simply consume,
but people who are actually praying on kids. I I don't know,
man. You have a little history yourself. I think some of this
might actually just be projection. No offense.
I'm not a You're a
Wait, is this There this somebody close to Destiny who's now
backing up the idea, bro. There's somebody close to Destiny backing
up the idea that Dan supported kids being groomed on Tiny Chat.
This is not good. You know what?
I am going to drop one. >> Every time I play this
>> and I am going to play this every time, actually. I
am >> guys. I don't defend it. I just play the video of
Destiny defending. >> Going to play this every time. I'm
going to keep playing. >> Guys, I don't I would never defend
it, but here's Destiny defending it. >> This every single
time. Okay.
>> Obsess over like people that watch. I don't know. Who
the cares? They're cartoons, bro. Who cares? Why are you so I
think
I think here I I I'll give a good example of of actual like why
defending it is worse than just simply actually being it. Right?
Let's just say you're a racist. Okay? You keep your thoughts
to your you don't really have to do this. We all understand the
like normalization
But you also defend it. You're literally playing a video to defend
it with by virtue of you're you're basically she's saying right
now I think you guys all find Destiny more compelling than me.
So I'm going to let Destiny defend it. This is a stronger defense
than anything she could muster herself. So she is going to play
this for her audience. That does more to normalize than just
the fact that Destiny had normalized it once before and it doesn't
excuse you from normalizing it yourself. You're using a more
persuasive figure to normalize it cuz you don't trust yourself.
You don't tell anybody else that you are racist. Um, and you
don't like unless you're being confronted with it. Okay? So,
you recognize that you're a racist. However, you're cognizant
of it. You don't try to actually do any real world harm off of
being a racist. Okay? You understand that this is not something
good, but you still are that anyway, right? Versus, let's just
say somebody who isn't racist,
okay? somebody who isn't racist who are trying to
>> so what about the person who's not who who isn't wait
who isn't racist dude I don't know how these hypotheticals
>> defend racist
okay somebody who is a moderate who isn't a racist says who cares
about racists dude racism isn't really that much of a big deal
yeah it's bad but who cares about that I think that they should
come in and do whatever they on anyway because honestly at this
point in society, racists aren't really that big of a deal. Who
is doing more harm? The person, the moderate who is not actually
a racist but who is trying to make an argument for racists or
is it the person who is um a secret racist but is not actually
going out and preaching this kind of stuff. Which one is it?
I hopefully, you know, and and if your answer if your answer
is it is actually the racist that is doing more harm, I'm afraid
you're lying because
>> what about the racist who every time they're asked like,
"Hey, don't you think this is bad?" You go, "Actually, here's
a way here's like a non-racist who can argue why racism isn't
bad and he's like way more compelling than I am."
Right? You're just using him for defense. I'm I'm pretty sure
that makes you worse. >> You don't actually believe that.
I've said this before and now that we've learned that projection
is real cuz it obviously is. I think the most likely place to
find are the people that are online constantly seeing on everything.
By the way, according to Steven's logic, okay,
it's probably just the fact that you've described attraction
to kids. The fact that you probably couldn't you'd have to cross
the street when you saw a kid walking down the sidewalk
because you were worried you were going to assault them. Like
that's probably the kind of thing we're talking about here. Not
really. Just like that. You consume
like with Vos. Uh actually Vos is a total DJ. But with Vosch,
let's say hypothetically the first thing you ever heard about
him was seeing like that one image.
I don't think I have that much criticism for him.
It's like, yeah, keep that to yourself, bro. It's embarrassing
it got leaked, but keep that to
Right. Come out, lie about it, be like, oh, I thought short stack
goblin. And then keep that [__] to your self.
Okay,
there you go. But that's not really the food shop's case. Okay.
>> Dan is a PDF. Yeah, I'm just going to say it. Okay.
According to Steven's logic, Dan is a PDF because the people
who tend to most be PDFs, according to Steven, are the people
who call other people PDFs incessantly. Dan calls other people
PDFs incessantly in addition to using it both as a joke and as
an insult and as an actual allegation, spiteful kind of thing.
If that is the case, according to Stephen and just keeping and
just trying to be consistent here, okay, this is just me trying
to use Steven's consistency. All right, Dan has a higher likelihood
of being a PDF than I am.
According to Steven, >> that would be in the case where
you are just a consumer of law who's kind of like off on the
side doing your own thing. That doesn't take any of the other
facts into into account here. I don't know why she's pretending
it does. She got to leave all that other stuff out and call Dana.
All right. Why can't we all get along? That's what I've been
trying to do. Okay. You see, I tried to deescalate first. I tried
to deescalate second. Okay. Made a truce. All right. The second
time. And
see, she's going to leave out the part where she was like, "Actually,
your wife getting harassed by Kiwi Farms was justified." Or whoever.
Sorry, I'm blaming on Kiwi Farms. I actually don't know that
Kiwi Farms was responsible.
I don't know if there's anything else going on in the background.
I know that basically Dan attributes it to KF. So she said that,
right? And then she said, "I don't care if your kids and wife
get like doxed and swatted." Pretty crazy. But she's just going
to leave that part out. She's just a peacemaker, guys. She's
totally the peacemaker here. >> The truth that he has agreed
to and then he decided to break it just today. So look, all right.
When the other side constantly aggresses on your territory, sometimes
you have to do >> We're good.
>> Something, you know, you have to do >> Sorry,
somebody's sending me a picture from the Hawaii trip or whatever.
This is This is the back of Dan.
This is not I know it can look photoshopped. It's not. It's not.
That's
That be real. That be real. Okay.
>> Okay. Never question it. >> You can't just let
something like this stand, right? Because guess what? It's not
my fault. I want to deescalate. I want to deescalate. Okay.
>> This is just like gaslighting.
Totally leaving out the bring his wife and kids into it. Very
weird. I think they're the most likely to be >> where you'll
be some. >> Dan has been has done been spamming spam banning
video who link your videos or disagree with him for 3 days and
he's still not over it. There have been two posts about food
shops in DG sub and one was sympathetic to Dan. Yeah. Guy will
be like, "Wait a second. Did you look at a kid in Disney World?"
This, by the way, this is this is what we call strien effect
and this is what we also call a lack of therapy. Okay.
When you are a middle-aged man, okay, when you are a middle-aged
man and
wait, what is Stryanding here? What What's being Stryanded?
Did she just totally [__] up Striand effect again?
I don't get it. Why did she use that word?
>> You cannot handle yourself
like a mature adult. I'm sorry. I I don't know what to say. Okay.
Also, not only that, just to reiterate,
all of us are pretty damn loyal to
It's not like we're anti-fans. You literally just called Dan
an anti anti-ban like 3 minutes ago. Like 3 minutes back in the
video, you called Dan an anti-anmuted.
>> It's not like we're anti-fans. All of us are super loyal
to Steven and and we always take the best faith interpretation
of your friend. You would think that he would be happier over
something like that over defending your friend. But to be honest,
the person who is undermining his friend the most is his own
best. No, I believe she said this was anti-fan behavior on Dan.
She didn't just call Queen an anti. She said it was anti-fan
behavior on Dan. What he was doing. >> Friend Dan hanging
out in J Stokes Discord server spreading malicious
>> Oh, look. She's literally doing it again in the ex this
exact moment. >> Perpetrating malicious allegations.
I think that's crazy. I'm sorry. That's just how it is. Okay,
not going to lie. I get where Dan is coming from. I understand
his arguments for why he thinks that you might turn around and
become an anti-fan. But if there's so much push back, bro, you
realize that by by now anybody could have become an anti-fan,
right? I'm not saying that me myself would like for example,
look at Mr. Girl, okay? He is so sensitive to everything and
he is so defensive himself and such a narcissist that he can't
help but become an anti-fan after
>> Oh, this is rough.
Mr. Mr. Girl was like her hero. Mr. Girl is like the reason she
decided to tell everybody that she was like a when she was attracted
to kids and
that's actually [__] up. She's literally
She's literally like her hero on stream and and burning him in
effigy just being like, "Is this enough for you? I love Stephen.
I I burn Mr. Girl. I burn him." Some push back or criticism.
Okay. He can't help it. He can't help but become a ni fan.
I have at this point I I think I've endured more than Mr. Girl.
>> What? What? Wait.
She understands that Destiny's only ever been 100% on her side,
right?
She thinks she's seen like the the worst that DG has to offer
because Dan dislikes her. Oh, what? Excuse me.
Excuse me. I think I've injured more more than Mr. Girl before
he turned.
Okay. Before he turned specifically. Obviously. Now Mr. Girl
like nobody has injured like in ter Mr. Girl is widely criticized
at this point. Okay. Um his reputation is in the but like I'm
saying before he turned before he turned by then.
Yeah. Getting streams by Dan and Counterpoints and Darius and
all the orbiters. What? Hello. Okay. All right man.
Good memes. Okay world. when you were at Disneyland, you must
have thought about them, right? Like, no, dog. Actually, like
I see kids all the >> I understand. No problem. >> Ever.
That's it's kind of >> And you know what? All I'm asking
for is understanding, okay? I'm not asking anybody to agree with
me. I'm just asking people to understand the, you know, the sequence
of events, okay? As in I keep on trying to deescalate, but this
person is like I I don't know, dude. This person is like they
essentially went after Dan's family and are like I just tried
to deescalate the whole time and there might be people in her
audience who actually believe that. It's very shocking.
I'm trying to take HER SIDE. STOP SAYING STUPID.
I'm trying to help. >> Dan keeps on acting like Hamas.
So it's like what can I do? What? Like what can I do? I'm trying
to iron dome myself. Okay. But at some point I have to strike
back right at Hamas. Like target a hospital or a school or something
because Hamas is hiding weapons under there, right? Like what
can I do? I'm Israel. Dan is >> you would like >> It's
kind of weird that you would think that I would though. Is that
like a
>> Okay. All right. None of that. Okay. Sorry. If you do
>> Oh, no.ism
in like >> you have 15year-olds in your Discord server.
I bet you try to them and send nudes to them and get nudes from
them and you over every thing they say in chat don't you all
the time like no not actually dog no that you know that man it
sounds like you got some firsthand experience that like I don't
know man sometimes there are people there are people that go
like really overboard sometimes when they like point out it's
like that guy's a
like how do you know he's a he drives right next to a grade school
on his way to work every >> these defenses seem really
motivated now like with everything coming out they seem very
very motivated >> and there are other routes that you can
take like okay is that like that's it for you that's the line
that's how you know like Jesus I don't know man because I've
like now I've seen so many now I've seen so many cases of projection
before where people will like project like this insane I hate
that this meme is real I hate that this meme is real but how
many guys do this [__] where it's like I respect
women's rights blah blah blah and then they get me too and it's
like so John the uh SJW understander the guy that logged in,
you know, two weeks ago tried to log into my when I stayed over
his house and I told him no like 27 times, you know, like it
feels like there's some feels like the projection might be real,
you know. I don't know. I just I'm just saying some people online
have this like really unhealthy obsession
with like constantly talking about I need to know the date of
this clip. If somebody can find me the date of this clip, it's
like here the resolution's low.
I just want to know how close in time is this to where he non-consensually
sends the pixie like tape like how collocated in time.
Okay, I just I have to know, man. I just got to know about
where they'll just be like
just scream about it. They're just so crazy about it. I was like,
"Damn, dude. You got
you two should talk directly and sort it out." Guess what? I
tried that. Yeah. every single possible like deescalatory step
that you can think of right now. I have tried it. Try talk offered
to talk to him in priv. >> I tried zooming in. It's too
low resolution.
Yeah, it's too low. Can't do >> Private and if he doesn't
even want to talk to me in private, why the would he talk to
me in public, right? He doesn't even want to add me. He doesn't
even want to hash it out. >> Hold on. It is his last apartment
in LA. Yeah. Before he moves to Miami the first time. It is.
Uh you could easily just search any line from in here in film
>> in private. He doesn't want to deescalate. Okay. This
is a man who is
don't like he feels as though his manhood
is at stake. Okay. So I Yeah. Again I I like
you came for this guy's family and now you're like now he just
All I said was I didn't care if his kids and and wife get swatted
and that it would be like good if it happened. That's all I did.
Why is he mad? Why is he mad that I was like, "Oh, it's good
your wife got harassed." Why is he mad about that? All I said
was, "It's good that your wife got harassed at work and I I'm
happy that your wife and kids got swatted in docks or if they
would get swatted in docks, I'd be happy about that." Why would
you be mad? Well, I don't know, MAN. IT SEEMS KIND OF NATURAL
to me. What can I do at this >> Seems like probably that
would upset
>> Got to have other things. >> I tried everything.
>> Maybe. Maybe not. >> You think I want this? Why
else would I deescalate?
Yeah. Anyway, cringe.
>> April 2021. >> Might as well earn some money.
>> Wait, there's no way it was April. So, it's a year.
It's a year later.
>> Hold on. Wait, what is the What is the Cardi date? Is
it 2022? When did this come in? Oh god, Google can't even find
this. Cardi is 2022. So, it's a year. It's a year until he sends
a Pix video >> off of it, right? >> However, I do
believe at at that time that's got to be close to the Bob 7 stuff,
right? It's got to be close to where he's sending Molina nonentally.
Luckily, he does a lot of non-consensual sharing of imagery like
throughout his timeline. We just go to a different example. It's
like pretty close on that >> Make some money off of my
own grief. My my own grief, right? I should What did Dan do?
Dan broke the ceasefire because he doesn't feel like a man anymore.
I >> Is it because I'm trans? Wait, hold on. Is it because
I'm I have to know whether or not it's because I'm trans. says,
"Dan thoughts." >> Oh, you said 3 months later. Very cool.
Very cool.
>> Is it worth fighting him? Hell no. It's not worth fighting
for me, both me and Dan. But considering how Dan has a large
access to the community that I certainly um am a part of, I guess.
And in addition to that, um a large number of that community.
Dan clearly cares about Queenman community. So maybe you just
need to convince Quman. Lol.
Yeah, you're gonna convince Quayman that you're not a absolutely
that it's like unreasonable to be concerned that you might be
a for sure by the way
conversation go particularly bad for you because Quimman openly
defends consumption of Quimman openly defends that and he still
criticizes you. So he's going to ask you to explain the gap in
information you're giving your community. It will not make sense.
>> Yeah. You know what it is my battle as well because
I have to defend my livelihood. I have to defend my reputation.
I have to defend my my my income. I have to defend my career.
Yeah, of course. Right. You can't just allow like he's currently
all right. He's pulling his like down. Okay. He's about to enter
the body. All right. And
you're asking me, "Oh, no. You shouldn't do anything. You just
let it happen." No. No thank you. Okay. >> I have the fattest
natural I already saw this fattest natural act. >> Like,
I'm sorry. >> Like, I'm sorry. I'm trying to defend my
job. Okay. He's going after my job. Like he literally is going
after my job. All right. So yeah, of course if somebody is going
after my job, what else can I do? >> True. That's an appeal.
>> Anti fans getting what they want.
You have no idea. That's true. Not a lot of truths happening
in food shops the chat today. But that one that one's true. I
>> Whoa. I don't know if I classify myself as an anti like
literally. But in terms of you think I'm an anti and I'm getting
what I want. Yeah. >> Black Latina. I mean, boy, you're
>> Okay, dude. Um, is there anything else regarding this
or is that the one clip? One clip. >> Hold on. Let's Let's
play it again. >> Do play it again. Give me >> again.
All right. >> All right. A little T. >> Just rewind
if you're confused. Okay. >> Okay. What we got here? >> Like
anything about this person for the last 6 months. Didn't talk
about them once. uh didn't say anything until I think mid to
late October. Um we first called them a naughty >> and
I sure think shortly after that I said it one time. >> Uh
and then from that was the one time by the way not multiple times
as they >> naughty by the way. >> I didn't call it
but yeah go ahead. >> Where the did my camera go? Hello.
Where where the [__] is this thing?
Okay sir.
>> does she just not remember?
You just not remember watching this the first time that you have
to like skip >> Oh, by the way,
how I can't tell whether or not you're more angry at me or you're
more angry at Hassan at this point. Okay. Like if you're questioning
who is more moral. >> wait, did I go too far forward?
>> maybe I did. >> My mic is quiet. No, my mic is
fine. Um
>> Oh, also, by the way,
>> I can't tell whether or not you're more angry at me
or you're more angry at Hassan at this point. Okay. Like if you're
questioning who is more moral, his son or me, I think at this
point I think you just probably should just log off and I don't
know, take care of your family. You know what I mean? Oh, keep
mentioning his family. It's going to go really good. Just keep
mentioning his family over and over again. That's the best path.
That's how you win food shops. Keep talking about his family
again and again and again. I if I were you food shops, I would
focus on focus in on his kids, right? Try to figure out as much
about his kids as you can. I think that would be healthy for
you to do. I think you would be doing great if you did this.
Okay, food shops. I think you're I think you're
that's where you should go for sure. Food shops 100%. Talk about
Dan's kids. See what happens.
Uh let's see here.
Oh, the anti you guys are like, "Oh, the anti fans dumb." Yeah,
it's obviously stupid. I lean into it because it's funny, but
like it's an obviously stupid thought terminating thing that
they just want you to not they want you to not think about any
what anybody else says. They want you to totally dismiss their
opinions out of hand. That's the entire purpose. It's completely
right. >> What is this? What is this? NSFW or Why is he
naked? >> Wait, what did she just show? >> What is
this? What is this? >> She pulling up Dan on the stream.
Let's go. What? What the
she going to pull up Dan on the stream or why is he naked? Oh,
okay. Okay. He's not naked. Um, why why is Dan a local at this
point? Why is Dan acting like an actual local? Like he he can't
he's looping. You know what I mean? He He's doing the local loop
thing. He can't help himself.
He can't help himself. He's doing the Dan Loal loop, right? She's
She's going to say why it's a local loop, right?
The Local Loop would be like
relooping on criticism all the time to like try to defend yourself
again. It's not like a localal loop to just be like this.
Right. Sorry. That's just not a local loop. It's just you're
like that person's a
Dan needs to chill on being aggressive orbiters. Yeah. So, there
was this Reddit post that was defending me essentially and
I I guess Dan didn't like it. We are needed in the trenches.
Oh, okay. So, they want to brigade it. I'm get I guess there's
an anti-free jobs post. I don't know who this person is. I watched
one video on my second monitor while playing League and it seemed
cringe.
Dan hates him. I hate him. Wait, is this really like the average
intelligence
of the Dan fan?
Is this actually the Bro, I I thought we had a cult. Okay, I
thought we had a cult. This is This is rough. Spider-Man pointing
at Spider-Man moment. Meanwhile, my Discord,
everybody's like this Jay-Z guy. Okay, I have I have an anti-ult.
Okay.
>> Dan hates him. I hate him. Seemed cringe. So you didn't
listen to the video then.
All right, man. Okay, cool. Thanks. I realized Dan looks like
he's naked in this. I know that immediately. By the way, why
are we allowing fruit chops to astroturf the Destiny subreddit?
No one is at the only I I think I think the only few times in
which I have asked one of my mods to make a post or something
like that, people noticed immediately that it was astroturf and
it got downvoted to Oblivion. But all the all the all the posts
on the subreddit that actually makes it to the front page and
actually like you know and are actually um
defending me against Dan. None of them was under my direction.
None of them was I I don't think I've seen anything in the server
that said, "Oh, I'm going to make a post like this." All of them
came out of nowhere. And all of them was like, "Oh, yeah, food
shops. Look at this. Look at this. Someone made >> Have
there been Have there been a lot of those or >> thread
about you?" And I'm like, "Oh, >> the [__]
is that pick? I maybe it's supposed to look like Dan." >> Oh,
awesome. A thread about me. Yeah, but just so you know, all my
attempts to astroturf has failed. All right, but this is C like
these posts are certainly not Astroturf. Okay, after all, remember
there is a post that is anti-me and anti-Zipzip
that also made it to the front page, but I guess you're going
to ignore that, right? Anyway, Push said she would
EIN what against Dan cuz DEG is supporting her, but she's going
to accept the ceasefire. Dan has the best record in D of executing
orbiters.
Okay.
What level of cope
are we on for you to say this? I'm just curious. What level of
cope do you think that this person is on?
How does most of DG feel about Zip Zip? Hard to say. Hard to
say. I do think that
Hold on. I do think that was it a DJer. I believe there are DJers
or former DJers who have posted some fan art of Zip Zip in our
server. I feel like Zip Zip broadly the opinions on Zip Zip could
be summarized by like a couple of these images.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Return the shoes, Zip Zip.
Return the shoes and you can you can come to whatever community
you want. Okay. We give you safe harbor in whatever community
you want. Just give the shoes back. Zip zip. Just give the shoes
back.
All you got to do
return the shoes. >> Okay. Whatever. If he wants the ceasefire
to be over, confine's over, guys. Ceasefire is over. Do what
you want. Okay? I don't care anymore. All right? If he really
wants to continue to call me a PDF or insinuate that I'm a PDF,
I think at this point,
that seems a little odd. That's far more of a call to action.
By the way, in terms of trying to say somebody's culpable for
harassment or doxing, I've never done anything like that. What
just happened right there. Yeah, ceasefire is over. You guys
do whatever you want. You go after this guy however you can.
It's like uh
ah >> yeah, I don't think I
food shops think they will win this in any way. They think they're
like an anime character
who get slapped with real life. I don't care anymore. Okay,
but honestly, I hope Fu Chops is an anime character and I hope
she literally like beats Dan in this battle and then they all
play Arc Raiders together and I can keep laughing that Dan hangs
out in a ped in a VC with a all day. That that would be for the
best. I think that is the best punishment for Dan to be surrounded
by so you never make those accusations himself. It's very funny.
Okay, that's that's really We do want food shops to stay around.
We do we do want her to be in the DG community where everybody
can keep an eye out, right? That's that's what we want, >> you
guys. Yeah. Do your thing, okay? Because if he wants to play
dirty, then fine. Like why should I hold my own audience to that
standard? Why should I hold my own community to that standard,
right? Like you want to you want to be weird, then we can be
weird, okay? Like what why why are you doing this? Like there's
nothing I have tried everything in my power, okay? within my
jurisdiction to calm down the situation and you keep on escalating
it because your manhood is being threatened by a trans girl.
This is just you are a high schooler. Okay? You never made it
out of high school. All right? And frankly, I'm going to take
away your G card. Okay? I don't think you des
Okay, hold on. Wait. Less ironic support, more actual support,
more actual critical support. Going to boot shops now. She could
have she could have taken Jake hard. What is being threatened
by a trans girl? This is just you are a high schooler. Okay?
You never made it out of high school. All right? And frankly,
I'm going to take away your card. Okay? I don't think you deserve
that. The smartest, most um oh, the smartest people on the face
of the planet who are side by side with Chinese people for the
model minority, I don't think you deserve to be at my side. I
don't think you're at the same level of intelligence, nor are
you at the same level of maturity, nor are you at the same level
of life experience. Okay, to be frank. Yeah, Dan, you are not
even close to maturity or life experience or anything with food
shops. The married man who started multiple companies is a millionaire,
is retired at like 45, and now just plays around on the internet.
You're nowhere near this 27year-old
trans neat. Yeah. Yeah.
Got him.
Got him. Okay. >> Okay. You seem like a 17-year-old, an
18year-old, a 15-year-old. It doesn't matter. Okay. You seem
like a edgy teen. All right. Whose manhood is being threatened.
So, you want to scrap after school. All right. I'm an adult.
I'm an adult. Okay? I don't have time for this. Okay? I need
to cover. >> I'm an adult. I don't have time for this.
I'm gonna go back to playing my my Slay the Spire clone
that has a disgusting lack of characters. Okay, >> Aspen
Gold, I need to cover the actual anti-fans, although you may
join them soon. Okay, I need to cover um I need to cover a bunch
of other [__] Okay, I don't have time for you because
you're insignificant to me. All right, so let's be very clear
where you stand on the totem pole. All right, you're nothing
to me. The only reason you you have a career right now, and you
know what? This applies to me too, but it applies even more so
to you. Okay, which is why >> Oh, I totally forgot. I totally
forgot. When she's like, she's talking about
Dan is retired. Video is louder than you. Probably. Uh, Dan is
retired. He had his career. When this person was out of streaming,
did they go to work in like a technical field somewhere? No,
they worked for the USPS. They were a mailman. They delivered
mail. Not that there's anything wrong with that, but dude, you
don't have like training. You're not somebody with
Isn't she at risk of being evicted right now? She's getting kicked
out of her current place cuz they don't want her around. Yeah,
but I don't think it's from lack of paying rent. I think it's
from lack of human interaction.
Lack of normal humanity, you know, normal human >> Obsessed
with controlling DG. The only reason why you have a career is
because Destiny allowed it. >> Damn. people. Um, listen,
the most uncharitable explanation for Dan, the most uncharitable
way to put this is like, not that Destiny allowed it, is that,
but it makes her sound like total.
Okay, technically.
Technically, Dan, the only reason Dan is there is because he's
willing to donate tens of thousands of dollars to Destiny over
a period of years to become friends with him. But that doesn't
really hammer home the doesn't have a career, doesn't have anything.
Does Dan know all the food shops a logging lore? Oh, he does.
He does. Boot chop should not be getting in this fight. She is
not going to win.
But hey, we listen. We just got the popcorn. Okay, we got the
popcorn out. We're We're enjoying ourselves. We're having a great
time.
But Dan's aware of all of it. And there's suspiciously just going
to be like a Twitter account one day that shows up. Okay, there's
going to be a Twitter account that shows up one day with all
of food shops's private info posting like a huge manifesto on
why they're and tagging everybody on Twitter. Okay. And that
will definitely not be because of Dan at all. That that won't
have anything to do with Dan. That definitely won't have anything
to do with them at all. It'll just come out out of nowhere this
will happen. Oh my god. Can you guys believe it? Can you believe
that thing that's happened to so many other people who've crossed
happened to food shops? Can you believe it? Oh my god, that's
crazy. Definitely nothing to do with Dan at all. >> Or
so to you. Okay, which is why you're obsessed with controlling
DG. The only reason why you have a career is because Destiny
allowed it. People were already coming to me before I even talked
to
on voice chat. You were nobody before
So, let's be clear on where you stand,
You're nothing.
You're pathetic.
And you should probably log off and take care of your family,
okay? It's a damn move to not care take care of your family like
this. Okay.
Anyway,
>> Executing orbiters. Oh lord. What level of cop are you
on? Jesus.
I mean, if she really thinks that she can deal with Dan,
you know, taking all of the information that everybody's collected
over the years and presenting it in a compelling way that she's
more confident that I'd be in her position. I if I had even like
onetenth of the that's in food shops past on the internet, I
wouldn't exist on the internet. I would be I would I would go
live in like the countryside. I'd become like a cabbage farmer.
I'd have my little patch of cabbages. Okay, I'm telling you like
it's not it's crazy that she's talking with this level of >> Let's
let's replay this. >> Never said anything about this person.
Oh, [__] By the way, food shops, okay? And by the
way, anyone who's enough to drawn uh art that makes them think
it's a kid. Okay, I don't give a >> Right. Drawn art
is a real kid being harmed. Are you I think you are the one that
is normalizing the issue way more than me just simply because
you are the one that brought it up more. And and just notice,
okay, counterpoints alone
>> By the way, this is what they argue about esports Batman
being mad about being doxed. They're like, "Oh, if it was really
a problem, why would you bring up that it happened?"
Like, it's just so twisted. It's all twisted, man. >> Up
more mentions of me and my drama and then me
across the entire year, across the last year after I ended my
hiatus. Dan at this point has also brought up my drama at this
point more than me.
more than me. Who is normalizing the topic? Who is normalizing
discussion of this issue? Who is normalizing discourse about
this issue? Discourse that you might find harmful. It's you.
But I don't think you
>> A Martini shaken, not stirred. >> It sucks, but
maybe you got to just ignore him. I think the anti-fans want
this. This will just implode on you >> Stop. Thank you
so much for the five Canadian.
No, I'm not going to ignore it. Why? Because number one, I find
it fun. Number two, I'm not actually that bothered by it. Number
three, hey yo, stop the cap. Stop the cap, man.
Dude, you had like a mental breakdown around this before.
What are you talking about? I'm not really that bothered by it,
actually. It actually doesn't really bother me all that much.
Uh-huh.
>> I make money and viewership goes higher when I'm covering
Dan Drama. All right. So remember, I have every incentive to
keep this drama going. The reason why I tried to deescalate in
the first place is just simply because
it's a courtesy.
It's a courtesy number one. Number two,
it still harms both of us in degrees that is not related to numbers.
Okay? And number three, okay, you don't want to appear weak and
divided in front of the anti-fans, but at this point, I think
that Dan is a detriment to Destiny, and Dan is also a detriment
to
Okay.
So true. I've heard he I've heard he inhabits the Jtock Discord.
Truly the greatest sin of all. All right. Inhabiting the Jtock
Discord. I started banning um
Oh, I asked if there's a way to ban anybody with like the food
shops tag or whatever. I'm just like very concerned that they're
going to start like like fed posting essentially
like they're getting kind of decimated on all fronts. I'm like,
"Yeah, we'll just get rid of all these people. People are all
suspected until proven otherwise." I say that I am I do want
to take her side.
yeah, I don't know, man. I feel like I feel like I'd be more
suspect of anyone who's in food shop server versus mine. Even
as a Destiny fan, you should be more suspect of anybody with
that food shops tag than you are of anyone with my tag. Just
saying. Just saying. All right. Supposedly, there's some big
truth. Dude, Dan is I I do agree though. Dan is a detriment to
Destiny.
Dan is like, yeah, nothing but downsides for Destiny. Think about
it, guys. But don't think about it like Boot Chops did. Actually,
think about it, okay? Like just when you apply your your brain
to the problem,
Dan like keeps bringing on he he keeps fighting with the Hassan
people, right? Like Destiny's fighting for his life and Dan is
like spreading their resources thin to go and fight Hassan people.
He's like brought about all this extra scrutiny. All these all
these Hassan people are like attacking Destiny.
Isn't Dan like actually a major detriment? Isn't he basically
doing the work of the anti-fans by making by making Destiny fight
on multiple fronts? Like really, shouldn't you all be sort of
focused in on destroying the anti-fans?
And Dan sitting here like, "No, no, no. Let's go get Hassan,
guys."
Man, I I don't know. Feel like there's a good argument for what
she's saying. She won't make it cuz she's like
functionally. But there's there's a real argument there, man.
>> So, I was begging from that did not happen. Okay, I'm
going to tell you right now. Don't give a creepy ass mother.
Stay the away from me. Don't come near me. Like like who do you
think looks bad in this drama right now? You should limit it
because it's going to get repetitive fast. That's fine. Okay.
I'm still going to farm him. All right.
But again, okay, what? I don't have time for this. All right.
Jesus. Yeah, sure. Yes, I understand. Okay. >> Wait. This
is a great argument to get sunset. This is really the only argument
that's required. Who looks bad in all of this? Actually, the
I think the looks bad. Yeah. Yeah. Couldn't have said it better
myself. The person who has credible accusations and a bunch of
clips that make them look like a That's probably the person who
loses when attention is drawn to that fact.
I'm I'm not operating, you know, this is this isn't rocket surgery.
All right. This isn't rocket surgery. We're not operating on
a rocket here. >> Okay. I understand the whole thing about
not talking about them. Yeah. Cuz I don't want to talk about
someone that's like literally off thinking that there's a kid
on the screen and it's like, "Oh, it's a loophole. It's drawn
so I get to do it." I'm good, fam. Off forever. I don't like
actually a [__] freak. >> Yeah. Yeah. I don't
think I don't think this is a joke. Okay. Sorry. Just wanted
to
apparently I'm so afraid of this
>> good farmer doesn't milk a cow dry. Sure. Look. Okay.
I think I'm justified just mainly because he has recently broken
the truth today. And I'm justified in the sense of like, okay,
I >> Well, here's the thing, Killinger. I don't think Dan
can [__] this up if he tried. I hope. I keep saying
I hope. I hope I don't hope Dan wins. I hope they both lose.
No, like there is just no way that this goes badly. Either food
Chops gets like totally obliterated, which is funny.
Or Food Chops somehow, like I don't think Food Chops can really
win,
but somehow Food Chops holds on and then Dan just has to hang
out with a on Destiny's community the whole time. There's literally
no losing. We can't lose. No matter what happens, we win. They
have They have put themselves in a situation
where we can't lose. We just win no matter what.
It's awesome. It's awesome. And that makes everything that happens,
every single thing. They could shut this down right now and I
do a dance of victory. It's It's fantastic.
Establish a choice of like notice how all these events isn't
because of me, okay? It's because of him. All these major events
are happening so fast because you you know how like in a workplace
where there's a sign that says something like oh
uh days without accident days without accident and then it it
says zero. It sounds like he never even knew about the truth.
No,
he he does know he does know about the truth.
He does know about the truth because he said it on his own live
stream on anything else live after I announced that there was
going to be a truce between me and Dan. So yes, there was a mutually
agreed to truce.
There was >> just a drink
>> because he announced that there was a truce and they're
not going to talk about me anymore
>> in a bad way, I guess. >> And who out when the
anti-fans were at their worst? I don't recall seeing Dan
>> who stepped up and who out when the antifans were at
their worst. I don't recall seeing Dan or Button. Lol.
Lol. Uh-huh.
Okay,
Sorry. I just real quick have to pull up this Logan Paul,
dude. Or is it Jake Paul? Is it Jake or Logan? That's rough.
>> True. Uh, well, I mean, Dan stepped up, but he failed.
Ah, thank you so much for the $5. Okay. Also, again, why should
I farm him? Okay, let me do my thing. Okay, if you don't want
to watch, then you know, just come back when I'm not covering
Dan. Okay, like every single time I cover Dan, it's only like
like what is it?
20 minutes, 30 minutes. That's nothing. What caused him to break
it? Was it out of the blue? Out of the blue? Yes.
>> Yes. Out of the blue? Yes. >> Sorry, I'm going
to pause right there.
>> It's fine. It's fine, guys. It's fine. We're going to
be okay. Let's put
some ice on it. there.
>> Anyone, by the way, who's doing any emote that's not
anything but a he's right is someone to put on a list right now.
Actually do like slash tag. Uh, >> don't let him or Quinn
bait you into being a focus. It's not I have never done that.
I I don't think that's ever going to happen.
But like
>> uh Oh, no. It'll happen.
I like I poke at Dan. Okay. I poke at Dan, but food chops went
totally insano mode and started talking about the guy's
how she's like happy they're getting harassed, right? I'm just
saying Dan has this is the Ethan Klein thing. It's actually kind
of up none other people. Dan just has the money to go like here's
$1,000, somebody go [__] with this person. You understand
that? That Dan can just go like, "Here's $1,000. Here's a bunch
of info. Here's like $1,000, $2,000. Go [__] with
this person." Yeah, I can do that. Like, you're fighting with
somebody you don't have the capacity to fight with and you don't
get it. Well, that's fine. I'm enjoying it.
Don't let anyone put you on the back foot. Food shop.
Food chops. Food job. Food chops. Uh, by somebody, do you mean
you? No.
No. I told Dan he could deal with his problem on his own. Cuz
if I go after this person in DG's mind, it doesn't make a difference,
right? I can present totally factual information on this person
and it doesn't make a difference to DGG.
If Dan presents it, then it makes a difference. That's all. And
I know that Dan's aware of a bunch of things about food shops
and she's about to push him into bringing all of that to light,
which is great. >> Like, what did we cover yesterday?
We covered Quan.
We covered Quman yesterday, right? We attacked Quman yesterday.
What I was planning on doing today, handsome gold. Notice how
I'm not the one that is bringing up Dan every single time, right?
Like I'm not the one that is bringing up the drama every time.
I'm always the one that is responsive, not the one that is
>> This person probably does it themsself. That's what
I'm going to tell you right now. Like uh who do we got in here?
Who do we got? Who's like uh being a little bit of defender
on a list? Okay, that's all I'm gonna say right now. And your
time is limited. >> Oh, is there another clip? It is. Let's
>> It is actually [__] limited. I can't believe
you people can vote. >> You should think of the conversation
you covered when you know the truth. The >> that wouldn't
count because I never made any personal attacks. I only criticize
his positions which is part of the deal. Part of the deal is
um I'm allowed to criticize his positions and expect tiff or
tat as in if I criticize his opinions, okay, and I criticize
his character, okay, then I should expect him to criticize my
opinions and him to criticize my character. And I think that's
entirely fair. Okay. However,
however,
it would it would seem as though it would seem as though I mean
again, if I went after his family again, right? If I went after
his family again, then yes, he is allowed to call me a PDF, right?
Because that's tiff or tat and I shouldn't complain about it.
But who is the one that broke that first? It was Dan. >> I
swear to God. Um, there needs to be a way to like cut the internet
of people who say tip for tap. Need to be able to cut their internet
automatically. Got to train these people out of this. It's like
actually just weird. It's soing stupid,
right? Dan was the one that
you know, all of this again, right, on his podcast, right? We
had a truce. Okay. He broke it. It's as simple as that. It went
after Quimman last stream. >> Who chops literally can't
see consequences one step past her actions. And that's another
point in the column. Yeah. Like there's a reason they don't just
say I for an eye. Goofy. >> Listen you guys. Uh Don, if
you're if you're watching with your wife right now, you guys
can watch watch the last VOD kick.com/fops. Okay. >> Ones
are the ones that are like Destiny defended this thing. It's
like, okay, is he actually doing that? Is he off the drawings
of that are supposed to be kids or is he just like doing it from
like cuz he's the one who's doing the said like is morally legal
type [__] Okay. >> I know one person that's
actually off the [__] pictures of kids. >> I
don't have the money.
>> Stay the away from me. I'm good with >> I mean,
what are you going to assume for do that? It's too much work.
I just seen the Destiny lawsuit. Um, >> that's stressful.
>> Zena the Witcher says Dan thoughts. Um, okay. Let's
see. >> Anyway, that's it. Um, okay. Let's take a look
at the second. >> Isn't just a drink. A martini shaken,
not stirred. Well, then I'll fund this war. Cause while Destiny
was all alone and everyone deserved him during his year, I was
able to watch you rip on JSTLK and Co. >> Thank you so
much. Uh, stoplight three. I appreciate that. Thank you. >> You're
the only person who could stand up against Chase and the anti
pants and we needed somebody. >> Doesn't Dan have a company
to run? That's what I've been saying. Okay. Also, again,
I don't cover Dan. Notice on after the truth, after the truth
is over, after the criticism thing, notice notice how I'm just
like straight up not covering him whatsoever. I'm not. Right.
I'm I'm upholding my part of it and I'm always asking I'm always
asking.
>> Wasn't this like censored before? >> Worm Slayers.
Worm Slayers is a former fan of mine. Okay. Also, why would you
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
DG has some of the Why do you think he's losing his like this
food? It's because he felt as though his masculinity is being
threatened. Okay. Because I made a dig at him. I went like, "Yo,
he is forced to be in the position to accept the truth." That's
what I said. Okay? And Dan probably took personal offense to
that because that's how I interpret the situation. Then fine,
okay? If you think that making PDF allegations is a good response
to your ego being
like threatened off of my read of the situation, even though
it was demeaning, demeaning you and insulting you in that sense
is not the same
as calling you or your family a PDF family. Okay? None of that.
That would be the equivalent. All right. Anyway, so Worm Slayer
is nice um ex fan of mine. Okay. There's an anti- freeze post.
Dan hates them. I hate him. Okay. Okay. I already know about
this. What's the What? What else? Unredacted version. Wait, none
of this is uh Yeah, I don't care about this. I got him to open
the link.
You also, just so you know. Okay.
Why would you pick a fight
with the person who has all the DG birdies on her side? Me.
Why would you do that? >> All of the DG birdies.
>> Okay. All right. I mean, do your thing, I guess. But
what's this? What's he >> This person. Oh, yeah. I don't
I don't give a >> She thinks she's bearish because like
two people who dislike me take screenshots of my totally public
Discord that she herself could easily just make a Discord account
on or a new Discord account for, join, and look at the messages.
But people like screenshot the the public channels and send them
to her. And she's like, "Yes, I I'm basically Varys. I have little
birds everywhere.
It's like it's like uh one
those the the birdies for Varys are kids and there are sinister
implications there by far more sinister with you. So you could
not that'd be great.
Okay.
But two, you're just reading public messages. It's not it's not
like cool. It's not like base. You don't have like background
knowledge. >> [__] troll the subreddit all
I want. All they want to. They're pathetic. What do you want
me to say?
>> What is this? >> Who's trolling the subreddit?
>> Oh, this is the That's me. That's me brigading probably.
Who gives a >> Oh, so he doesn't admit to brigade. Cool.
Good.
>> That is the thing about Dan. When Dan engages in immoral
behavior, Dan goes, "Yeah, of course I'm doing that you." >> As
I said, it's fair game. >> Yeah, you look so good right
now. Once again, two posts. Okay. All right. Oh. Oh, sorry. This
is MVTT calling him out.
God, this is so cringe. Why is he so cringe? Oh, so this is in
response to this, I think. Um I I think this is MVTT um baiting
Dan. Okay, you broke it. You have no idea what you've done, Dan.
I will defend food shops. You're inexplicably insecure, threatened
by a tiny after hours drama streamer that streams for two to
three hours a day. Okay. Or 4 hours if I'm feeling nice. Proof
of food's burging the subreddit.
>> Oh, okay. And then and then it links this one. Oh, okay.
So, that's what it was. Ah. All right. So, he admits Okay. So,
he admits to breaking the truth, guys. He literally admits to
breaking the truth. And he admits to brigading the subreddit.
I guess everything is okay after. >> Okay.
So, from there, it seems like it's all over, right?
You you might think so. I do believe from this point Dan just
pulls up. Okay. Dan goes, "Yeah, that's all true. Now explain
this clip where you said you have to cross the street if you
walk by a child. >> But you are open about it Trump style.
>> Uh just a drink a martini shaken not >> How are
you fighting with Dan while there's a genocide actively going
on? >> You're right. We need to focus on the Gaza Strip.
Here's a tip. Your thighs are more contested than the Gaza Strip.
Yeah. I'm sorry. I want to watch this again. This is him responding.
Okay. >> This person Oh, yeah. I don't I don't give a [__]
They can troll the subreddit all I want. All they want. >> I'm
not trolling the subreddit. What do you mean? >> I'm doing
No, I'm not doing any of that. >> What is this?
>> I told my people to stay back.
Just by the way, by the way, I told people to not be so mean
and unhinged.
Did I not say that? I said that because we have a truce going
on, we should we should like dial it back. That's so
What? Why would you Okay. All right.
Can someone can someone explain to me why Barry Weiss would get
in the way of a Secot documentary coming out? I actually don't
know. Like I don't want to just do the super on the nose analysis
of like, oh, it's human rights abuses. It'd be similar to something
going on in Israel, so she pulls it because blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah would make Trump look bad.
Is it really that simple? Yeah, I know you tried saying something
earlier. I'm just asking about the motivation. I just don't get
why she's supposed to be a liberal. She paints herself as a liberal.
Oh, >> thank you, Dan. Nice argument. Secott is not an
immigrant immigration detention center. Secott is a like high
It's like a highsecurity, lowquality of life prison in El Salvador
where they happen to send immigration prisoners, but it's not
like an official US facility. It's in El Salvador. Yeah. So,
I just I don't understand why this prison and the the rights
abuses that would happen and it wouldn't be relevant and and
somebody who's a liberal wouldn't want a documentary published
on it. You see the response from the journalist. No,
>> That's me. That's me brigading probably. Who gives a
I love the brigade.
>> As I said, okay. Okay. In case you're wondering who's
in the right. Okay. If you see this clip, if you see this clip
of Dan admitting to breaking the truth into brigading the subreddit,
and you still think to yourself, okay, maybe Dan has a point.
I'm sorry. You are lost. I am not for you. You do not have any
principles any kind of >> Dan's point is that you're a
and that you're hiding that and that he has evidence that you're
a
>> I I don't know what she's not getting about this. What
is she not getting? >> Integrity. You only care because
you're a Dan fan and you're willing to break rules for him because
he thinks breaking rules is great and epic and awesome and being
a is awesome and being an is awesome. You know what? Okay, do
your stuff. All right, I will not get in your way. All right,
but just so you know, in case you're wondering if from a third
party perspective who is right, I am right. Okay, I've abided
by the rules of warfare, but Dan is the one that decides to go
Hamas. Okay. Anyway, how is FA's even capable of brigad?
>> Oh, I don't. Too bad. >> The fa subre is like
10 people to active. I mean, Dan is literally encouraging brigading
on his server. It's so silly. >> And and he got triggered
by Destiny anti-fan of all things. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't understand. These people like make a game of just
lying.
Like it's not it's not even really defensible things they say.
It's strange.
I'm also
I might have to look into the CCOT thing tomorrow.
>> Okay. Anyway, is this our October 7th? Yeah. Well, our
October
72.
I I don't know. Just I don't I don't I don't get it. I don't
understand why he did this.
response to the sidelining.
Okay. Well, maybe I'll look at it real quick. >> Dan has
his own Discord. Well, he's got a redact discord and then he's
got the anything else discord.
Yeah, probably.